and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're going to talk
about creativity we're gonna talk about
creating more and consuming less and
we're gonna talk about the the
difference between creating content and
producing meaningful creations and we're
gonna answer your questions with today's
guests who better to have on the show
who better than Matt D Avella when it
comes to creativity you can find his
brilliant videos on on YouTube we'll put
a link to that in the show notes thank
you for joining us today Matt thank you
so much for having dude thanks for being
here it's when I think about creativity
and like watching someone have a journey
from creating some stuff to being like
super popular adding a ton of value
having you know millions of viewers man
like I think you are you're kind you
were kind of like the you were the best
example of that man I mean it's funny
you guys were on the creative journey
with me pretty much from the beginning
when we made minimalism and and you guys
know firsthand how complicated and
sticky it can be oh yeah I see I can get
yours that I saw was most wedding
videographers suck starting to come into
making original content and it was like
the first thing I put out there and I
remember at the time like just admiring
you guys and the fact that I think you
said something or you liked it and I was
like but it was a little bit negative to
start well no the thing the thing about
that was I'm like he's right most I mean
I think the reason that most wedding
videographers suck is people have this
idea of like man I'm I'm really
passionate about filmmaking
I think the easy way for me to make
money right now the low-hanging fruit is
well I need to go film some weddings
because yeah that's hoop that that's
where the demand is that's the most
demand for low in low-budget filmmaking
is in the wedding industry right and so
what you did was like well I I need to
make some money to I'm gonna find a way
to set myself apart from that which to
me what mimicked a lot of what Ryan and
I did when we first came into the whole
minimalism thing like there are other
people do
writing about minimalism but we had a
unique perspective and also I had been
writing for a long time so I took that
that bit of creativity and a rough
writing fiction and said okay let's tell
a different kind of story a nonfiction
story and you've done the same thing
with with film where it was like I'm
gonna find a way to to tell the story
through this lens through through this
medium of filmmaking and we worked on
the documentary together and from there
you've just continued to to create and
so we're gonna answer some questions
today about creating our first question
today is from Heather in Asheville my
question is around maybe some journaling
prompts or something to kind of help
work through this energy that I've had
that used to be surrounded by and
editing things in my closet you know
I've been really into like the
minimalist game and purging and things
like that but I found that I still
really have the urge to buy and I can't
really always control that so what I'm
looking for is like what is that next
step in in processing these emotions and
that and that extra energy that is left
over when I'm not letting you know this
is a fascinating question because I
think Heather's asking the right kind of
question I've got this extra energy and
I don't know what to do with it reminds
me of Ella my five-year-old like she has
a lot of extra energy and she doesn't
know what to do with it and so it can
manifest and rage or as US adults it can
manifest often and like well I need to
do something with this time I might as
well go buy something and for me I think
one of the antidotes has been to to
create more Matthieu you you spend a lot
of time creating them I mean you're
essentially doing a documentary every
week on YouTube I mean they're they're
shorter documentaries not 90-minute
excursions but still a lot goes into
that I remember we were working on
minimalism you must have had a thousand
hours of sunsets try to film like three
or four sunsets and it just completely
failed like the Sun never came up dude a
couple couple of those time lapses
worked out really well but it took
getting like a million of them
to get the right line and it's hard to
do that on a consistent basis every
single week it's about buying things and
then editing her closet I mean that to
me that's really what the creative
process is about when the thing I teach
my writing students in my writing class
is which is how to write better to work
by the way if you're interested but the
at each you have to sort of build up
this mountain of sediment before you can
go panning for gold and the same thing
was true with with minimal so in fact
this next thing that we're working on
right now we've had at least two three
failed attempts at finishing the this
the second documentary or film or
special whatever we're calling by the
way that has nothing to do with you I
mean it's one third year fall together
but that's the thing is you sometimes
you you you film all this you spend your
resources your time your energy
sometimes your money like we did back in
February of last year and it doesn't
work out how you want it to work out but
that's okay that's all part of the the
sort of creative process but that's
where our energy goes and you learn from
that you're learning a lot from making
these these films what are you learning
about about creating right now a lot I
mean I find for me you have to replace
perhaps negative or bad habit with
something positive so you know I've done
a lot of experiments like a 30 day no
social media experiment 30 days of
waking up at 5:00 a.m. which I'm in the
middle of and which is brutally painful
and I wouldn't recommend to everybody
but you have to replace it so when I
quit social media the first thing I did
was then start to go to cnn.com/fareed
and then you you can very easily fall
into a negative pattern and I found for
me and this was true when I originally
got into minimalism when I decided okay
I'm not really interested in consuming
more of getting as many material items
as I can to prove to other people and
myself that I'm successful I decided to
put all my time into filmmaking so it
was that replacement or saying alright
now I'm not gonna be focused on
consumption I'm gonna be focused on
creating something more productive it
was really cool about that is Matt he
took this this medium and actually
aside for a second he was like well let
me go this other traditional I'm gonna
try to start blogging about this and
then he started a podcast which is a
really good podcast followed by the
ground-up show y'all can check that out
but the thing that you really succeeded
at is that thing that you had cultivated
into a passion it wasn't like a you had
stumbled into it like oh yeah you you
came out of the womb with a Canon c100
or something like you you found
something that you were interested in
and and it aligned with what you wanted
to do creatively and you really
cultivated that and yeah you have some
you have some beautiful like inherent
talents like the way that you see light
it's amazing we were out on tour with
you like you Matt will be in the most
the strangest place filming some of them
like is he filming Ryan's shoelaces
right now I can't tell what he's doing
but at the end of it you're like oh like
he saw something there's some talent
there but most of the text you just
skillset it's it's failing failing
failing your way to success in a way
yeah I think actually it's interesting
you even say that just you guys
observing me creating and for the
longest time it's it was very easy for
me to create an acai low and create by
myself but then when I started bringing
on collaborators and that's always one
of the biggest things I said that helped
us create minimalism and get it out
there was that we had this
accountability to each other that you
guys would ping me and be like hey Matt
how's the edit coming Oh how's it when
are we gonna see V 3 or V 4 V 20 and it
was this constant making sure that we
knew each other's vision and understood
where we were going with it and when
you're by yourself it's it's easy
because it's all in my head but then
eventually when you guys came on and we
decided to create this big project
together I had to then figure out okay
how do I take this creative process out
of my head and explain it to you guys
and also be able to understand what your
vision is and what you guys would like
to get out of the film and I think that
was one of the biggest learning lessons
I had from from doing minimalism and as
I continue to collaborate on other
projects
yeah I felt like it was a pretty
painless process I mean there was a
couple hiccups like you know the Fargo
incident where you sent us like you were
really excited about this new version
you're like I've totally redone it in
like us inspire like we watched it we
were like oh man
like this is not this is not the movie
we were expecting or you know it wasn't
emotionally-driven like like the
previous versions work now we thought we
were being pawn he's wasting our time I
don't know man I don't think I don't
think Matt's a time waster man I don't
think it would brilliant what he's doing
right he's he's just he's stomping on
our expectation what was cool though man
is like we could we could go to you and
we could be completely open in a I don't
want to say in a positive way cuz like I
mean telling you like all dude like no
it's an easy for you guys I remember it
being very painful for you guys yeah oh
me that you weren't into the film and we
respect your vision your opinion right
yeah but ultimately like because we
respect each other vision and opinions I
mean it was a hard conversation to have
but I felt like Matt as a creator I
don't know how I would have reacted if
people came to me and were like like cuz
you put your heart and soul into that
man I don't know how I would have been
like you were so cool about you're like
well okay like you know I turned off
Skype and started crying now I think I
handled it pretty well I think I was
most disappointed with the fact that I
thought from that moment on I was never
gonna be able to change the film in a
new direction but then once we were able
to continue talking about the creative
process and about how this film was
going to evolve going forward we all we
knew that there was changes that need to
be had that gave me an opening to
possibility to say okay well I didn't
think version 1 was it you guys don't
think version 2 is it but maybe there's
a version 3 that we can all get together
to find that would be even better than
the first two yeah and it was I talked I
totally agree that that's what you ended
up doing yeah ultimately it was from
what I remember was the ninth version is
what ended up on Netflix and that there
were subtle iterations between there's a
lot of them toward the end it's like
minor tweaks like let's move this here a
little bit and you spent days removing a
hair from Dan Harris's jacket okay okay
I didn't so that was actually really
frustrating yeah there was a hair on Dan
Harris his jacket for the entire
interview I took it out in the trailer
but then during the actual interview of
the entire film that would have taken
about four weeks
but yes I was a bit relentless on the
details yeah and and that's important so
a couple things here to finish up
Heather's question she talked about the
urge to buy I think I think the what's
more powerful than the urge to buy the
urge to consume is the urge to create
sure and you have to find that urge
though it's not it's not as simple
actually it is as simple it's not as
easy as well because you can't buy the
thing and you've completed the task
doing the work completing the task is
actual drudgery its heartache its
headache its difficulty it's working
with people on a team I work much better
by myself like Matt Matt was saying but
what we produce as a creation is better
because we work as a team totally agree
Heather um I do want to give her a heads
up like you could buy all our books who
listen to all our podcasts you still
will have that urge to buy like it's not
about getting rid of that urge to buy or
ignoring that it's finding a healthy
replacement like you were talking about
finding a habit that's going to replace
buying the other thing I'll tell you -
Heather if you've got time on your hands
give Matt go out there go find a soup
kitchen I mean it's crazy like Mariah
now we've been like kind of stalling on
and putting off like doing anything in
Hollywood and there's like there's a
food bank just man like two or three
blocks from our house that will go to
every once a while and just like help
them prepare food and man like that is
to me like that's feel that feeling is
just as good as a feeling as if I had
just created something so Heather like
yes if you if you want to create awesome
create if you want to go out there and
give back go out there and get back but
the beautiful thing is Heather you got
the time you've got the attention -
don't - give to those things so do it
yeah you know what's fascinating about
that sometimes they intersect - I mean
the whole reason this minimalism thing
has worked well for us is 90 plus
percent of what we do is all free this
podcast comes out every week it's it's
it's free people can listen to it so
we're able to contribute to other people
but also do so with what we're creating
whether it's the writing on the blog
whether it's social media whatever it is
and that I've noticed that with you it's
all the things that you're creating help
people so ultimately what Ryan will
you're talking about find ways to help
people maybe that's through your
creation creations maybe it's through
using your resources in a different
the thing that's important is is the
action the verb or the thing I like most
about Matt's work is he's less concerned
about being a filmmaker or a director
and he's more concerned about making
films yeah so so rather than being a
well yes I am a filmmaker now I can go
to these cocktail parties and tell
people I'm a filmmaker
no he'd really he'd rather make really
beautiful films that help people in
someone go to cocktail parties and don't
invite me Matt I was thinking about this
question this morning man like how the
Heather's
Heather's question made me think like we
are in a constant state of like either
taking or giving like if we are if we're
you know sitting down and watching TV
like we are consuming this podcasts like
we are giving energy and so the question
is Heather like where where do you want
to put your energy obviously you don't
want to take as much that's why you're
stopping to buy but but yes I guess kind
of looking at and that light help me
realize like wow like really there's
kind of this you know binary thing
happening either you're giving or you're
taking yeah and I would say too when you
are consuming try to be mindful about
that because she Heather did mention
that there were these urges for her to
consume and there's likely a reason for
that and it could be childhood trauma
but it could likely be that she's
watching she's seen commercials yeah in
her social media and news feed she's not
actually taking control of it a lot of
people get frustrated with social media
and with the images that they're seeing
without realizing that they have a lot
of control over what shows up in their
feeds that is a great point man like one
of the best ways I like curbed my buying
impulses it was cutting out as many
advertisements as possible like
magazines were huge for me like I didn't
even realize until like I really started
being deliberate with my time on my
resources you know the the GQ
subscription I had I didn't realize like
how that stuff like totally seeded it's
like oh man I gotta get that Alexis is
full of ads each month ships to you
right yeah and then you replace it with
the minimalist podcast exactly and
you're moving in the ground a podcast
well one last thing she asked for some
journal props have got two for you one
is what do I want to create today or
maybe what do I want to create this week
and then how do I want to help or how do
I want to add value I think that's a
really good place to start
also now that I'm gonna send you a copy
of our book everything that remains it's
a story about Orion and I we took this
sort of five-year journey from being the
suit-and-tie corporate guys who were
really focused on on consumption and
buying our way to happiness what did
that lady say in the figure what paper
in tirana was she was like two guys
divorced their wives and move out to
Montana yeah on the back I'm like
that'll happen but not in that order
right we've got it all wrong but okay I
put in the same sentence and what we did
what we did is we found how we could
better add value to people's lives how
we could create by getting rid of
majority of the consumption doesn't mean
we don't need some stuff and as matt
said we now consume a lot more
intentionally we still fail and we
document a lot of those failures a lot
of the successes and a lot of how we
create and what we create in that book
so if you like our podcast you'll love
thee or you'll enjoy I'm still teaching
all of this love people use things right
we don't love tacos I love people yeah
you won't love the book but I think
you'll enjoy the audiobook version of
that she loved the experience of the
book yes yes indeed love and enjoy the
experience as well and hopefully you'll
like it as well
but uh or we'll send you the book book
or the e-book whatever you want
everything that remains a memoir by the
minimalist Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from the social medias indeed
we do we're at the minimus on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram and at Matt dia
Vela on all the relevant social
platforms right how dare you have more
followers than us know that we're
everywhere so Matt people can tweet it
to you they can Instagram at you like an
I don't know if that you snap or
whatever all the other kids are doing
that's it I'm grameen not even that much
though I delete Instagram from my phone
and then only
download it and I just kind of go in
phases now it's fun to be connected but
at the same time it's very easy to let
that get yeah I deleted from my phone
because yeah like I well I am like a
habitual scroller and then the worst is
like oh well the worst slash best is
when I go to the suggested videos and
it's just like snowboarding video after
surfing video after wakeboarding video
after skateboard video and like you can
just scroll up and yeah just keep
scrolling up and like gets reprise
that's always great but yeah right so
during lighting around swear we all do
our best answer every question but
there's a short shareable less than 140
character response we also put the text
of these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
pithy quotes all of our minimal Maxim's
in one place minimal Maxim's com
alright our first question is from Rhys
how do you know whether you're creating
something because you love it or because
you feel like you have to do it
so my pithy answer to this and we can
talk about it is an obligation to
produce can kill creativity it's the
videographer thing right like I have to
show up for another two weddings this
weekend and then I have to like edit it
and you're like I have to do this this
isn't now some people might transcend
that I bet you there were some amazing
wedding videographers out there who were
like I get to do this yeah ostensibly
like it looks to me as a filmmaker like
going into that type of field it does
allow you to have some type of
creativity but it is different when like
a like you're trying to create something
you're trying to do you know put your
stamp on it but then you also have like
this art by committee thing with the
bride and groom or like they're telling
you what they want so yeah I don't know
it's it does turn into a half-two in
which which sucks when it does happen
turns into like content generation I
have to generate this content we see
that a lot with social media now in fact
during the maximum episode I'll talk
about I just found this article about
how Instagram hungry crowds are
destroying the super bloom which right
we'll get to and so Matt the thing that
that I let you use the word content
quite a bit but really I don't I don't
see what you do as creating content I
see what you're doing is you're
producing meaningful creations you're
creating creations it some people might
even call it art to a certain extent
right but but for me when I look at it
you're not just trying to fill the space
but the thing I learned from this
article that we're gonna talk about Ryan
is I hate Instagram but it's that's also
the reason I think we need to use it now
I want to talk some some more about that
but but Matt let's talk about content
versus creating and let's try to answer
Reese's question here do you ever feel
like man I have to do this and if so
what does that do to your creativity
there are certain parts of the job
especially when you're a solo creator
that you have to do like I have to do my
taxes that I love it I could certainly
outsource it if I wanted to but what I
would say to Reese is if if he has to
even ask that question he probably
hasn't found it yet
he probably hasn't found something that
he really loves yeah because when I
started out as a filmmaker it was before
YouTube and my audience was very small
it was family and friends and while I
have a big family I didn't have many
friends
yeah very Italian like like seven kids
in our family Italian and so my audience
was a couple dozen people and I could
definitely see people today putting out
a video on YouTube only getting 24 views
and resigning to the fact that they're
never going to make it or that they're
never going to continue to upload videos
in the future and to me that's that's
crazy because if you really love it if
you enjoy the process you should be able
to make and upload videos for two years
and only get 24 views and be happy with
it because you love making films now if
you're going to be able to dedicate all
of your time to it if you're gonna be
able to make a career out of it that's a
different question and one that I think
should be questioned seriously because I
don't think we all can just spend 40 to
80 hours a week doing purely what we're
passionate about if it's not gonna make
us any money right you don't have to
create something at all I think if I
think it was Chris Brogan
he he he had a
good blog subscribers for the first nine
years Wow and and that shows you but he
got good at that craft of blogging that
became his art in a way and his way of
writing is sort of and I mean this in
the best terms it's like diuretic like
he just it's it's like expressionist the
throwing of Jackson Pollock thrown paint
against the wall but he does so in a
beautiful way
and and I think we can do that but
you're right it doesn't it doesn't
require a large audience to to have to
communicate something to an audience
yeah my pithy answer is this whenever
you pick up a boulder of obligation you
can just as easily set it down so Reese
yeah if you are in the half to mode and
you don't have the time to carry that
Boulder or the strength of the energy or
whatever resource that you're lacking
set it down like that's that's okay I
will say sometimes like there are things
that pop up in my head that I have to do
and it's not because of an obligation as
much as because I want to do it's like
you know when Mariah and I we were
living in Missoula and we were talking
about country music and I'm like Mariah
I can like totally make a country song
but give me like an hour and I will and
I will write in like will record and she
helped me a little bit but it was like
it was this thing we're like I had to
you know as a Saturday we you know we
weren't didn't have like you know some
like solid plans to do anything so I was
like in this boat where I was like I
have to do this like I absolutely have
to take these next two to three hours to
like write this and then record this and
I do which I'll never put out but
because it's really not that good for
all intensive purposes like it's a
really crappy country song you you you
you you it wasn't me I have to do this
it was I have to do this and there's a
difference just in the inflection like
if you italicize your inflection they're
almost that changed everything because
we're you're really saying is wow I
can't believe I get to do this I'm the
last one yeah yeah last tour we were on
like every time we go onstage you played
me I can't believe we get to do this
yeah or how this is our life how amazing
is this right and and getting to do it
through all the drudgery because you
still get to do it yeah it'll get to
create
when we first started the minimalist men
I mean it was like after that packing
party it was like oh wow like we have to
get this this information out there like
it wasn't anywhere else and it was a lot
of work it was it was drudgery but but
it was something we yeah had to do or
got to do and I I guess like Ries maybe
you can differentiate between having to
and having to to sometimes
procrastination can confuse us mmm where
it lets steven pressfield's the war of
art where we have this resistance to sit
down and do the work it's not that we
don't love writing and we might love to
write but sitting down to write is
actually the hard part so I think once
we get over that and if you can actually
find something you enjoy in the process
that's what you have to focus on not the
feeling before you ever even get started
yeah the war of arts a great book the
last chapter kind of lost me but if you
like the angels that are around really
like really celestial but anyway great
book podcast I will put that in the show
notes if anyone wants to read it our
next question is from Zak what would you
say is the key to delivering essentially
the same message but always having
something new to add it's what you mean
by the same message my short answer is a
new light on old ideas changes how they
are perceived and really what I mean by
that is like these ideas that are in
everything that remains or in any of our
books or podcasts whatever they're not
necessarily new ideas occasionally there
will be but they're they're remixed
ideas the problems themselves are new
and so what we're doing is we're taking
a new sort of light and shining it on
those ideas showing people different
perspectives and that was important when
we first started writing about
minimalism our perspective was different
from Leoville Delta or Courtney Carver
or Kym and Joshua Becker was a different
perspective and also we started using
different mediums as well and so writing
is one one medium writing blog blogs
versus writing books or two different
mediums as well you communicate
something different you use them to
express differently but there's other
ways to express whether it's film
podcast social media et cetera
yeah I think my dumbed down version
of that would be creativity is looking
at the same problem in a different way
and for me the the first video that
really started to take off and gain
traction for me on YouTube after a
year-and-a-half of uploading videos was
an apartment tour and like by any
stretch that's like a really boring
video it's a concept that's been done
thousands of times but I thought oh how
can I bring something unique to this how
can I bring my personality my sense of
humor my editing style to this to make
it something different and unique and
just because it's been done before it
doesn't mean it can't be done
differently better for your audience or
more interestingly yeah absolutely
my pithy answer is this consistency is
more important than new-and-improved
Zak don't get caught up in trying to
reimagine yourself I mean how many
freaking times have I talked about the
packing party I mean consistency is way
more important than new-and-improved
I was AK I would encourage you to find a
message that you believe in a creation
that you believe in and just work on the
consistency and as you evolve allow that
that work to evolve I mean with the
minimalists I mean certainly we have
some different opinions and different
viewpoints now versus you know nine or
ten years ago so be open to that but
don't force yourself to be new and
improved because it thinks it likely
will about to really help me with this
on our tour in 2014 we're in San
Francisco we were like right halfway
through our tour city number 40 or 45 or
something
do you remember what city San Francisco
was his memory his memory needs upgraded
no but but yeah it's it was somewhere
like almost in the middle the tour and
Leo was like so how's it going man I'm
like dude it's going really well but I'm
like giving this same talk over and over
again and the sentiment is there but I
find myself because I knew the talk so
well I would find myself sitting there
like like Mike
sounding like a robot right now do these
people like is the sentiment coming
through and man you know I think I saw
that person at our last tour stop and
they're just hearing the same thing and
alia was like dude he's like first off
like you really have to you know choose
that one person who's there for the
first time envisioned like that's who
you're talking to right and it's funny
cos like that's why we started the
minimalist in the first place it wasn't
about like oh there's how many people
were gonna reach it was more about like
I know that this story's gonna help a
handful of people and other other people
out there who this is going to help so
he kind of helped me get back to there
but then the other thing he said to me
he's like did and even if someone has
seen your talk ten times like hey
they're choosing to see it for the tenth
time he said but repetition is so
important when learning and especially
when you're trying to change your habits
like repetition is well that's the
mother of all habits right so so yeah I
don't worry about new-and-improved Zach
worry about being consistent it looks
like we have several more surprise
questions this week about quieting the
inner critic about finding the right
medium to create within about detaching
from creative outcomes to enjoy the work
itself about creative work and financial
stability which I know is the difficult
one for folks who want to branch out and
create on their own also I want to talk
to Matt about how success changes
expectations and how it changes what he
creates both good and bad and if you
want to hear all that you can listen to
this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the space
we need to talk about the topics we
don't usually discuss in public plus
patreon is the best way for us to fund
this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app you also
get access to our entire back catalogue
of more than a hundred private podcast
episodes find all the details and all
the good stuff including an additional
podcast episode a private podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists com slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week
you know man we live in a very meme
culture right now a lot of headlines I
mean that's why I got off a Facebook
honestly it's like someone would just
throw up a meme and then be like BAM
there's my point enough said
the problem is memes are not enough
memes aren't enough so yeah being
informed is more important than ever
especially today so I just want to
encourage people like I usually do at
the end of episode to read more and get
informed and now here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
first-time caller I am calling to
respond to something Cory said on
episode 176 the unamerican dream he was
calling to ask you if you thought that
buying a house would be his next step or
should be his next step sounds like he
follows the Dave Ramsey plan he said he
paid off all his debt and after he has
an emergency fund page he feels like the
expected next step would be to buy a
home he also said that he wasn't sure
that was something he should be doing
because he wasn't happy in his job he
didn't feel the need to put down roots
where he was and I want to speak to that
because I did recently sell my home I do
something like this my husband got his
dream job and retired us to move across
the country but we owned a home luckily
we were able to sell the house and an
acceptable amount of time for us to be
able to afford to new but that does not
always happen in the markets can change
suddenly so that's something sporty
really needs to take into account when
he is thinking about buying a home and
whether or not he is going to want to
move I also want to say that if you are
renting and you are doing the Dave
Ramsey steps there is no reason why you
can't start saving for a home in case
you do move to somewhere amazing and you
want to put down roots there hey this is
Helen from Karlsplatz California I just
wanted to make a comment about the
podcast about health you guys were
talking about sleeping patterns and
figuring out your own sleep schedule and
there was something that I accidently
figured out a couple of years ago when I
had evenings to myself all alone in my
house I had a lot of windows in the
house and I would just be doing my own
thing and get distracted the Sun would
go down the lights was dim and suddenly
it was 9 o'clock and the house was
practically pitch black except for maybe
one
like that was pretty dim in the corner
and I realized by that time that I was
very tired and I was ready for bed and I
was curious because before I was feeling
up to maybe 11:00 across midnight and I
looked up to see what exactly this meant
and I learned that when we are not
surrounded by artificial lighting and we
go outside maybe and we're outside all
day our energy goes with the Sun so as
the Sun sets our energy slowly declines
and our body gets ready to rest for the
night and so for those who are having
trouble with sleeping or trying to
figure out their pattern or whatever it
may be I highly suggest doing that to
keep all the lights off except for maybe
one or two that are really necessary and
see if that helps see it as the Sun Goes
Down their party gets ready to sleep and
they can have a good night's rest
all right Joe thanks again to Matt dia
Vela for joining us today make sure you
check out his beautiful videos your
you're giving up coffee soon for are you
giving up coffee for 30 days I am it's
gonna be a month or two what's what's
great about these these 30-day
experiments like we've done a bunch and
written about them on on the website but
I love what you're doing with the video
version of it and it makes it a more
visceral in a way and so I think it's
beautiful what you're doing you can
check out all his videos on his YouTube
channel I'll put a link to that in the
show notes and real quick four right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
three years ago Ryan and I we
accidentally opened a coffee house
kind of yeah oops well it was we took
minimalism the data the documentary not
even the final version but we wanted to
help our friends of photographers Joshua
and Sarah Weaver and they were leaving
their sort of creative jobs and they
needed some help getting this coffee
house open so we're like hey let's let's
screen this documentary there we'll
bring some more audience in at least
bring some awareness to the coffee house
when we get down there like hey our last
loan fell through and I don't even know
like they weren't officially open when
we went there no I hadn't opened and
they're like we're only doing this
because we promised you guys that we
have a shop that you could screen your
documentary in but we don't know if
what's gonna right
and and so anyway I've been over three
years now we've been roasting our own
coffee for the last two years it's in
quite a few restaurants and coffee shops
throughout the south and southeast and
we help them open this coffee shop
together we became partners and the
business we're also bringing food to the
business so if you get a chance you want
to stop in to our coffee house in Saint
Petersburg Florida
it's called bandit and we think you'll
really enjoy being there it's a
minimalist space you've been there I
have made it there yes it's what I love
is like I will
I just blast it all whenever I can like
man bandit is the best coffee house in
st. Petersburg Florida it's the best
coffee house in Tampa in Tampa I really
do believe that and then the best
feeling is when people reach back out to
me they're like yeah you're right man
it's awesome such a great staff there I
mean it's not just just Josh and Sara
it's Seth and Chris and everyone else
and who works there and they do such a
good job of curating the space making it
beautiful we're adding a restaurant
component we're roasting our own coffee
and if you can't make it down to Florida
you can now find that coffee online it's
just bandit coffee dot Co bana coffee co
we're doing the minimalist choice as
well yeah and here's our current
minimalist choice we give to Matthew
Vella that's right so what we do is we
just basically pick our favorite coffee
that the roasting at the time and
there's actually not a ton of that left
the what is that the the Kenyan yes yes
so good anyway you're gonna love them in
before I quit coffee this is great also
like no one want you to call here right
now and just smell it it torture me but
I like to talk about creativity we were
talking about this before the podcast
like how would somebody start a coffee
shop or brewing coffee in 2018 would you
start at 2016 or so you guys they
started together and it's like you can
find a way if you do something a little
bit differently a little bit more
intentionally yeah and the thing was I
we it was such a shoestring budget like
we we opened this coffee house on a very
minimalist budget it was it was probably
about 1/5 what you needed to open a
coffee house but we it's the same thing
with the documentary there was no budget
for that you just came along and slept
in hotel rooms with us we shared beds
and stuff like no weird
well in a good way that will happen when
Ryan's around anyway if you have a
question a minute a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm and you will also
receive our simple Sunday emails each
week for our added value this week let's
listen to the song it's called win the
party's over from Billy eyelashes debut
album it's her new album it's called
when we fall asleep where do we go she's
one of my favorite new artists and her
music is just like you'll hear in the
song it is haunting in all the best ways
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
thanks guys and minimus